kyle wright is 24 years old 6-4 215
huntsville alabama is his home out of
vanderbilt former first round pick by
the braves the fifth pick overall in
2017. and poked off the end of the bat
to center field that's going to drop
so dickerson bloops one into center and
the marlins have the lead off batter on
base for starling martay
and he promptly bounces this one to
echeveria dansby glides across the bag
and doubles up martay wright needed that
two for the price of one bases are empty
on one pitch on the way from the
right-hander ground ball to the left
side charging and gloving knee-high as
reilly gathers and throws and that is
out number three good inning for kyle
wright base the minimum no runs a hit no
errors none left we played a half an
inning and they are getting their first
look at the prized arm of sixto sanchez
people are hitting 103 off the changeup
three for 29 that's his pitch 2-2 pitch
coming from sixto and he went around
strikeout number one for sixto sanchez
tonight so the player of the week in the
national league marcel ozuna six doe
comes set again his pitch and it ran
inside and it jammed ozuna who grounds
the ball to third anderson's got it
fires to first base in time though zuna
ran hard trying to beat the play but if
not kyle wright saw the minimum in the
top of the first inning faces matt joyce
to lead it off in the top of the second
and joyce smacks one out to right field
acuna junior turns and that one is gone
over the top of the wall matt joyce with
a solo home run his second marlins home
run one to nothing marlins here in the
second the 1-1 pitch
is golfed into left center field ender
on the run and makes a nice diving grab
that ball was tattooed cooper hit a
rocket ender with a fine play
and he struck out over the inside corner
that's the pitch that bertie likes him
to throw and it served kyle well it's a
second strikeout
broken bat dansby will charge and he
will make the flip to first in time and
that retires the side a homer and a
single gets things started for miami
they lead one-nothing austin reilly to
lead things off riley beats the shift
sprays that past aguilar at first base
and an opposite field single for austin
reilly who continues to impress at the
plate good start for the braves they
have their first leadoff man aboard
tonight
and there's a strikeout 100 miles an
hour two for six though and there's two
way in the second six doe to the plate
and it's grounded right to third up with
it anderson fires to first for the out
and sixto works around that lead-off
single jorge alfaro leads off the third
the marlins lead the braves one nothing
tonight in atlanta
and el faro with a drive out to right
center field that's where his power is a
solo home run for alfaro
now first home run of the season for
alfaro a no doubter plants to second leg
kick in the 3-2 swung on and miss got
him swinging
fastball up and in here's the 2-2 to the
plate
swung on and missed came inside with
that fastball again two down here in the
third inning there's the payoff pitch
from right swung on and missed got him a
fastball
following that change up on the last
pitch hey that ends the top of the third
inning so the marlins have to lead off
man on base for the fourth consecutive
inning against wright looking to extend
this two-nothing lead
and cooper drills this one to left the
goes out of the yard to left field how
about that a low line drive garrett
cooper a two-run shot and it's four to
nothing a chance for more with the
runner at third and one out in the
fourth
and that is smoked an rbi single for
jorge alfaro five-nothing miami lower
struck out his first time up six doe has
pitched four shutout innings so far and
he
strikes out flowers
he got him down and away with a changeup
and he chased it and he's down on
strikes for the second time the pitch
a swing here and nci hits a high fly
ball right center and going back on the
track as matt joyce
runs it down makes the catch and a one
two three inning here in the fifth for
sixto
tyler matzik in his second inning of
work works to jazz chisholm swinging a
miss chisholm's down on strikes again
and strike three freezes dickerson nice
comeback for matsik as this game moves
to the home sixth and ronald lacuna
junior is leading off six doe sanchez
first pitch strikes 14 of the 18 batters
faced
and a called strike three inside corner
his fifth strikeout and here comes the
payoff pitch swing and a miss 99
upstairs six strikeouts for six though
six doe to the plate and freeman swings
and lifts a fly ball to left going back
on the track making the catch dickerson
and that's all for the braves in the
sixth and the marlins have the bags
loaded with one out here in the seventh
for garrett cooper
ground ball through a base hit aguilar
will score to keep the line moving six
nothing marlins two on nobody out best
chance of the night sanchez can do
nothing but look on two and two and he
gets him to chase one down below the
zone the strikeout for james hoyt went
away in the seven yeah it's one of my
favorite pitches from james a two-out
walk loads him up with two outs the
infield plays back for the marlins blyer
comes set the o1 and darno rolls one of
the shortstop rojas has it underhands to
second hitting over ryan anderson the
batter looking for his third hit
he's two for two with a walk and hit by
a pitch and he bangs one through the
left side he's got a base hit that'll
knock in jesus aguilar to set the pitch
and a ground ball to the shortstop they
go to second for one and on to first for
two
and a run scores
so now the marlins have an eight to
nothing lead